in this video i show you how to test
your data for normal distribution
first of all why do you need normal
distribution
let's say you've collected data and you
want to analyze this data with an
appropriate hypothesis test for example
a t-test or an analysis of variance
one of the most common requirements for
hypothesis testing is that the data used
must be normally distributed data are
normally distributed if the frequency
distribution of the data has this bell
curve now of course the big question is
how do you know if your data is normally
distributed or not or how can you test
that
there are two ways either you can check
the normal distribution analytically or
graphically
we now look at both in detail
let's start with the analytical test for
normal distribution in order to test
your data analytically for normal
distribution there are several test
procedures the best known are the
kolmogorov smyrnoff test
the shapiro wilk test and the anderson
darling test
with all these tests you test the null
hypothesis that the data are normally
distributed
so the null hypothesis is that the
frequency distribution of your data fits
the normal distribution
in order to reject or not reject the
null hypothesis
you get a p-value out of all these tests
now the big question is whether this
p-value is greater or less than
0.05
if the p-value is less than 0.05 this is
interpreted as a significant deviation
from the normal distribution and you can
assume that your data are not normally
distributed if the p-value is greater
than
0.05 and you want to be statistically
clean you cannot necessarily say that
the frequency distribution corresponds
to the normal distribution you just
cannot disprove the null hypothesis in
practice however
values greater than
0.05 are assumed to be normally
distributed to be on a safe side you
should always take a look at the
graphical solution which we will talk
about in a moment
so in summary
all these tests give you a p-value if
this p-value is less than 0.05
you assume no normal distribution
if it is greater than 0.05 you assume
normal distribution
for your information with the kolmogorov
smirnoff test and with the anderson
darling test you can also test
distributions other than the normal
distribution
now unfortunately there is a big
disadvantage of the analytical methods
which is why more and more people are
switching to using the graphical methods
the problem is that the calculated
p-value is influenced by the size of the
sample therefore if you have a very
small sample your p-value may be much
larger than
0.05 but if you have a very large sample
your p-value may be smaller than 0.05
let's assume the distribution in your
population deviates very slightly from
the normal distribution then if you take
a very small sample you will get a very
large p-value and thus you will assume
that it is normally distributed data
however if you take a larger sample then
a p-value becomes smaller and smaller
even though the samples come from the
same population with the same
distribution therefore if you have a
minimal deviation from the normal
distribution
which isn't actually relevant
the larger your sample the smaller the
p-value becomes with a very large sample
you may even get a p-value smaller than
0.05 and thus reject the null hypothesis
that it is a normal distribution to get
around this problem graphical methods
are being used more and more we'll come
to that now
if the normal distribution is checked
graphically you either look at the
histogram or even better at the qq plot
if you use the histogram you plot the
normal distribution in the histogram of
your data and then you can see
whether the curve of the normal
distribution roughly corresponds to that
of the normal distribution curve
however it is better if you use the
so-called
quantile quantile plot or qq plot for
short
here the theoretical quantiles that the
data should have if they are perfectly
normally distributed and the quantiles
of the measured values are compared
if the data is perfectly normally
distributed
all points would lie on the line the
more the data deviates from the line the
less it is normally distributed in
addition data depth plots the 95
confidence interval
if all or almost all of your data lies
within this interval
it is a very strong indication that your
data is normally distributed your data
would not be normally distributed if for
example
they form an arc and lie far away from
the line in some areas
if you use datadep in order to test for
normal distribution you get the
following evaluation first you get the
analytical test procedures clearly
arranged in a table then come the
graphical test procedures how you can
test your data with data tab for normal
distribution i will show you now
just copy your data into this table
click on descriptive statistics and then
select the variable you want to test for
normal distribution for example age
after that you can simply click on test
for normal distribution here
and you will get the results down here
i know the test procedures are not
actually descriptive methods but if you
want to get an overview of your data
it's usually also relevant to look at
the distribution of your data
furthermore if you calculate a
hypothesis test for example whether
gender has an influence on the salary of
a person then you can check the
preconditions for each hypothesis test
and you will also get the test for
normal distribution
if the precondition is not met you would
click on this and a non-parametric test
the man with the u test would be
calculated the man with new test does
not need normally distributed data
thanks for watching and i hope you
enjoyed the video
you